do you believe that
men are designed to follow our Primal
instincts uh for you know having as much
sex with as many women as possible or
you know do we have a noble and divine
calling for sexual Mastery and that it's
better to maybe Master our sexual
Instinct within the boundaries of
monogamy
um I'm more see uh
I've looked at it from different angles
you know at this point and when we last
talked it was several years ago when was
it 2018 or 19. maybe yeah yeah
um yeah I know you've you've been
married for a long time you're happily
married and sorry just to correct the
statement I didn't get dragged through
the divorce court I know that sometimes
people
um misunderstand
uh divorce and how it works you don't
necessarily have to go to court and it's
ideal not to if you want to get an ideal
outcome and remedy so everything I did
with my ex-wife was subtle outside of
that through negotiation back and forth
with lawyers and that takes time but
um I'm not a big fan of marriage as an
institution because it invites the state
into your home and it allows and as a
Libertarian like as a sovereign man I
don't want the government telling me
what I can and can't do I don't want to
tell me what I can and can't do with my
wealth access to my children any of
these things so
it works out for some for some guys for
for many guys it really doesn't
um it's amazing that you and your wife
went together for the song you've got
four great children out of the whole
deal and we were talking off air before
about how that's going and I'm stoked
for you brother like I'm very happy for
you but the path that I'm at is at at my
life
um and the stage of the matter I've got
a kid that I've got to finish raising
obviously
um I'm divorced I'm out the other side
clean I got a great girlfriend uh we've
been together for a few few years now
she's uh she's a wonderful compliment to
my life you know if he adds value she
does a lot to improve it she does a lot
to improve my kids life she's great with
my family I just don't see the need to
invite the state in my life and declare
in front of the church or in front of
family that I put this ring on her
finger and want to be with her forever
and ever until kingdom come because I
know how things work
um there's a lot of lyrics that you hear
tossed around she's not yours it's just
your turn blah blah blah sort of thing
and I think that men have a innate need
to scatter seed that's that's why we can
produce millions of sperm per month and
women only can produce one egg that's
just the reality of the Sexes men and
women are not the same they're different
you already know that I think most your
audience already knows and agrees with
that whether you choose to be monogamous
or to be non-monogamous that's your
choice
um when you take a look at the evidence
in the way that humans have arrived at
where we're at today some choose a
spiritual path and they want to declare
monogamy and uh tune into that part of
life and that's cool and others uh don't
and that's cool too as long as you're
putting yourself first and you're
getting the results out of life that you
want and you're not hurting anybody I
don't see anything wrong with either
path
okay I can totally dig what you're
saying there you know
as far as not hurting anyone else I'm
curious like so we both agree that the
sexual Revolution uh at least I think we
agree uh has been a Scourge upon
Humanity a big part of what allowed the
sexual Revolution to unfold which has
given us out of the mess that we have
right now
has been the uh the Advent of
contraception mainly uh birth control
pills you know if we're kind of like
wanting to live based on our Instinct
right and do like you know what our
Primal nature is what are your thoughts
on uh on contraception and it's a means
by which we've fallen into this mess
yeah uh hormonal birth control seems to
be the Catalyst that has contributed to
a lot of the results that we have in
society today decades later now right
um because before there was there was a
very real problem or risk that if a
woman was promiscuous she could end up
pregnant and if you end up pregnant and
you don't have a provider to protect you
and the child then chances weren't very
good for survival
a lot of that's changed now though we
have the government who's now you know
big daddy you know the head of the
household you know in many cases it's
you know that's why divorce law
introduces itself into your life you
know when you get married or if you have
to untie the knot you don't have a lot
of control you still have responsibility
as a man
under the rule of the government but you
don't have a lot of authority in your
own household when you invite them in so
the Advent of hormonal birth control has
given women
freedom to do as they choose it's uh you
know with the access to safe and
effective abortions as they call it it
gives them the ability to terminate
pregnancies even if the hormonal birth
control doesn't work or they forget to
take it or they're lazy with taking it
or whatever it happens to be but there's
not a lot of consequences for bad
choices anymore a lot of things are
forgiven oh take this pill if you want
to have free sex I'll have an abortion
if the free sex doesn't work out oh you
can't afford the kid that you have
that's fine the government will you know
step in and take care of things oh
there's a guy that you can extract
resources from family law will step in
and and steal from him and alienate him
from his own children so there's a lot
of weird things that happen as a
consequence of giving giving women free
reign to sleep with as many guys as much
as they want in a fairly safe fashion
and that's in my view one of the great
contributors and failures to Society at
the same time why we're here today
yeah what what are your thoughts on a
male's responsibility to you know turn
away from that and not participate in it
by having you know sterile transient sex
with you know dozens of women who you
know obviously are sterile yeah do we
just you know kind of indulge it's like
hey there it's free sex let's just take
it Take debate or do we have a
responsibility knowing what we do now to
say no
it's it it seems like indulge is is the
path most chosen you know at this stage
right it's women have been promiscuous
you know what are you gonna do like one
of the things that I've heard critics
say is well it's it's men's fault that
women are like this today you know if if
women are then men are are
make are makers for creating the
promiscuity that exists because if men
didn't indulge with women then they
wouldn't be promiscuous
but I don't think you're going to change
a man's nature he sees a beautiful woman
with curves he's going to want to
indulge it's always been that way
self-controlled is
the new conversation that you're
bringing up where it's like you know if
you subscribe to a certain belief or an
organized religion that prescribes
certain behaviors or lifestyle choices
then you're encouraged to follow those
but guys find well my you know my
biological Drive is still to indulge
because why shouldn't I you know she's
indulging other guys are indulging why
can't I indulge sort of thing
um so
there's a lot of different paths that
you can go down at but to the point of
the original question it seems like most
men have chosen to indulge and when I
say most I'd say the vast majority of
the population including women so it's
like you're not going to turn the clock
back and all of a sudden stop indulging
in women uh because men just won't
um and women won't because they get the
free attention they've had this for
decades now I don't think you're I don't
think you can put the genie back in the
bottle if you know what I'm saying right
like this is out now this is where we're
at how do you now navigate it so that it
best serves you
yeah I I can definitely see what you're
saying um just playing a thought
experiment right so you know uh the laws
have been designed to
hurt men in terms of marriage you know I
won't argue with that I can see it it's
very obvious it's it stacked against us
um what if there was a proposed law that
we could band together and pass that
would eliminate birth control like do we
have a responsibility to do that as men
to say that if we're gonna if the genie
is out well we have a we are in control
we do have power
um the same way that they got the power
to vote and to do all these other things
that you know kind of screwed us uh
could we
if we could should we
do away with it
well the if we could question starts to
lean into other areas as well because
you hear guys saying if we could repeal
the 19th Amendment then women then women
couldn't vote and we wouldn't end up
with bad political choices and wars and
you know uh
experiment you know yeah you know like
you could cook up a whole bunch of ideas
that could potentially solve everything
I don't think you're gonna
how can I put this I don't think that
you're going to find
I mean if women accepted that you took
away their birth control pills let's
just say they did
I don't think that lasts several decades
what was it 1960s 1970s I mean it's been
50 years it's just called about 50 years
I don't think the last 50 years of
cultural programming societal
programming are going to make women uh
chest virgins again they're not just
going to get right with any anybody or
anything and say I'm not going to sleep
with anybody until marriage now
right I don't think that you can do that
I mean if you slept with 50 if you
shared your body if you've laid with 50
100 men you can't all of a sudden
declare well I'm going to remain chased
until my wedding day right
because those 1500 men have been printed
on her they've done things to her she's
carrying baggage around now as a result
of that so I don't see that repairing
the problem
sure yeah it took three generations to
get here at least to regenerate it'll it
might take more to reverse it yeah I
think it I think it's going to keep
going in the direction that it's going I
don't think that we're going to
turn back the clock and end up closer to
where we started back in the 60s
if that makes sense
very cool all right I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're newer to the channel make sure
you hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out